michael weiß heute abend grünen wähler
waren früher schlecht in mathe die
wähler waren schlecht in deutsch es
klingt jetzt erst mal wie ein bösartiges
abgedroschenes vorurteile doch eine 1
bach umfrage hat das jetzt bestätigt wie
die welt berichtete also grün wähler
waren der umfrage zufolge schlecht in
geschichte und auch die matte stand
viele grün anhänger in der schulzeit auf
kriegsfuß ganz anders als bei den
anhängern der fdp die waren besonders
gut in physik man sollte solche umfragen
selbstverständlich nicht
überinterpretieren aber mich überrascht
ist mit blick auf die überteuerte
klientel politik der grünen nicht so
ganz erst die nicht ganz so gut in mathe
sind also ich schließe mich der these an
wer grün wählt kann nicht gerechnet und
jetzt würde ich aber erstmal gerne von
ihnen wissen denn sie die
fdp-politikerin sind sind sie den guten
physik gewesen und er hatte
recht
zu den wenigen die da nicht in frage
stattgefunden haben also insofern ist ja
auch sehr fraglich ob die umfrage uns
irgendwas zum wählerverhalten
tatsächlich weiterhin keine ahnung wurde
es wurde geschaut wie halt wähler welche
partei sie wählen und welchen fächern
sie gut oder schlecht in der schule
waren repräsentative umfrage aber
selbstverständlich muss man ja auch
nicht überbewerten haben sie das gefühl
dass die grünen gut rechnen können
darauf kommt es ja gar nicht alles kommt
darauf an dass man gute politik macht
und wir müssen aber auch um politik zu
machen muss man ja die wirtschaftlichen
zusammenhänge das soll man das sollte
man sollte auch die grundzüge der
sozialen marktwirtschaft verstehen da
gebe ich ihnen vollkommen recht das gilt
ua zion im moment ist es besonders
wichtig dass wir gucken dass die
staatsausgaben hier nicht überhand
nehmen und wie christian lindner
zurechtmacht die schuldenbremse auch
einhalten das ist ganz wichtig sonst so
beisein der ereignissen wie pandemie
ukraine krieg hätten wir sonst niemals
die rücklagen gehabt wenn man nicht
vorher auch daran gedacht hätten
schuldenbremse einzuhalten diese so
finanzieren deswegen ist ganz wichtig
dass politik rechnen kann und soziale
marktwirtschaft versteht haben sie denn
das gefühl dass der herr beck als
wirtschaftsminister rechnen kann dass er
auch genug daran denkt dass sie die
schulden bleiben sobald wieder einhalten
müssen ob er jetzt als minister rechnen
kann das kann ich überhaupt nicht
beurteilen
wichtig ist dass die koalition insgesamt
sich darauf einigt dass man jetzt
besonnen guckt und schaut was ist
wirklich an staatsausgaben
und was ist jetzt vielleicht einfach nur
der situation erstmal geschuldet gewesen
und das da die koalition jetzt sachlich
darüber diskutiert und christian lindner
macht das finde ich sehr vernünftig und
seriös
ja aber ich sage das auch ganz gerne und
soweit hier an der strecke und halte das
für ein ganz ganz wichtigen punkt den
wir auch noch mal einbringen können in
diese koalition
er spricht viel sie sich denn von der
ampel als bürger gut vertreten das gut
auf dem steuergeld geachtet wird dass
die gut rechnen für uns alle also lang
beim heer fahren habe ich euch schon
über diese studien ich würde ja gerne
rein hauen und sagen ja genau er ist es
weil das passt ja alles so schön die
vorteile die man so hat aber ich weiß
leider wie vor sich damit soll
vorsichtig man an solchen studien
umgehen muss da gab es auch schon mal
vorher eine studie zu grünen und suv
fahrer kam raus die meisten suv werden
von grünen bestellt der was dann die und
statistik des monats weil sich
herausgestellt hatte so einfach geht's
nicht unbedingte wahrscheinlichkeit dass
das stichwort da nicht berücksichtigt
hat also sei es wie es will aber werde
ich jetzt davon komplett vertreten na ja
nicht so ganz allerdings muss ich auch
sagen wir haben natürlich eine situation
dass haben sich glaube ich die fdp und
die grünen und alle nicht so gestellt
der in rheine krieg auch die
wirtschaftliche lage wir haben ja
sozusagen alles das was für einen
perfekten sturm wie man so schön sagt
nötig ist und ich weiß nicht was da noch
kommen mag niemand hat sich das glaube
ich gewünschte und ich möchte nicht in
ihrer haut stecken
und es war ein volk es so weit sind sie
denn jetzt eigentlich vorher so würden
sie gerne in deutschland leben sie leben
ja in österreich als deutsche und würden
sie denn gerne bleiben die politik ist
denn jetzt weiter also ich find sie
beide grauenhaft okay ich bin
entsetzt über die entwicklung der
letzten zwei jahre ich bin eigentlich
auch ein stückweit überrascht weil ich
mir denke es hat sich völlig umgedreht
ich wäre mit sicherheit vor über zwei
jahren noch in grün wähler gewesen hätte
auch die linksliberalen durchaus gern
unterstützt aber
natürlich wahrscheinlich hält das zu
sagen aber
aber für mich hat das alles nicht
umgedreht ich mein es wird seit zwei
jahren auf minderheiten gepusht von
jenen parteien von den ich mir erhofft
habe dass sie für die minderheiten sind
also ich bin ja einer der eher liberal
unterwegs schauen sie die kurve
situation an was dann mit leuten
passiert die ein bisschen kritisch sind
und ihre meinung äußern und wie die
letzten endes nicht gehört werden dürfen
also das sind für mich dinge dass das
ist in der politik die ich nicht
akzeptieren kann und dann gibt es
parteien denen ich nie und nimmer eine
stimme geben würde wollen die aber
durchaus jetzt plötzlich genau die
unterstützen die auch kritisiert ich
rede von seiner partei auch die fpö in
österreich
dafür gerne aussprechen egal also er
mich ist es so dass ich alles gemischt
hat und ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
mehr weiß was zu wählen ist und das ist
vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht
ist es eine krise und ordnet sich vieles
neu und es kommen neue parteien und da
bin ich sehr gespannt was die schaffen
in österreich ist die msg sehr
interessante partei in deutschland ist
es basis noch nicht so weit wie die
etwas gehen österreich aber immerhin
also das sind für mich
interessante neue entwicklungen in der
politik genommen
ich glaube ich kann mich da wirklich
mein vorredner anschließen also mir geht
es da ähnlich also ich wer bin ich
eigentlich nie im grün wähler gewesen
bevor sie fragen ich bin auch schlecht
in mathe
also ich habe auch das gefühl also
tatsächlich dass das nicht so unbedingt
die werte sind und das was etwas was ich
mir darunter vorgestellt hatte noch vor
einigen jahren dass da jetzt
saniert wird oder oder welcher kurs
gefahren wird und ich bin gerade auch
was inklusion angeht natürlich sehr
aktiv und habe da auch oftmals das
gefühl passt ja dann auch zu dem was ich
da so was ich später noch sprechen werde
das da oftmals auch einfach ein bisschen
was vorgegeben wird in vielen bereichen
das dann nicht eingehalten und sowohl da
auch speziell etwas vor ich habe das
gefühl dass es auch so ist ja dass er
sich überhaupt teil greifen den rängen
ja ja